is the traditional laptop dying well in
this video we are going to find out
because we have lenovo's brand new yoga
book 9i which is the world's first
full-size dual screen OLED laptop
compared to Apple's M2 MacBook Pro
around the same two thousand dollar
price point this one starts at 2100 this
one's for 2000 which of course you can
get right now on Amazon for only 1800
bucks but in this video we're going to
be testing everything including the
designs thickness usability performance
display quality everything to see if
this is a better choice in 2023 now
everybody knows what the MacBook looks
like so we're going to close this set it
aside and take a look at this crazy new
design right here as you can see we have
dual displays both OLED they look
absolutely incredible but one thing you
might not know is that this thing has a
360 degree hinge check this out oh it
folds all the way down like this which
is absolutely incredible and even better
this middle part right here actually has
speakers built into it as you can see
right here it has Windows hello support
so it has all the IR sensors everything
built in right here and it also has this
kind of outward reverse Notch which
helps you kind of open it when it's
closed like this so it's not going to be
a pain there you go just like that now
what's really unique is that it also
comes with a keyboard and this special
case that's actually used as a stand and
of course the pen all of which I'm gonna
get into in just a second showing off
the really cool and unique modes you can
use these dual displays in but first I
want to compare a couple of things to
the MacBook Pro especially the ports
Lenovo packed in three Thunderbolt 4
ports which is awesome on this thing
especially how light these little
display sections are and right here they
also have a little which that cuts out
the camera as you can see right there on
the display now on the MacBook you also
get three Thunderbolt 4 ports but they
outdid it by far they have the max save
3 port for charging so that means
another Thunderbolt 4 port is open they
also have a headphone jack HDMI and an
SD card slot so definitely better ports
on the MacBook Pro and now let's compare
these size and thickness as you can see
the Lenovo is quite a bit smaller and
more portable than the MacBook Pro look
at that and surprisingly even with dual
screens and very good screens at that
it's still thinner than the MacBook Pro
now before I move on if you love this
type of dual display setup on the yoga
book you'll love the geminos monitor
from mobile pixels featuring basically
the same setup with ergonomically
designed dual stack 24 inch monitors
which requires very minimal desk space
thanks to its built-in base that has a
bunch of extra ports packed in it's also
great for MacBooks as well with monitor
angles that can be quickly adjusted and
pivoted to match your preference and
height of the built-in 1080p webcam so
check out the geminos dual stack monitor
using the link below now as far as
comparing the keyboards and the track
pads as you know Apple's magic touchpad
or trackpad is the best in the business
you literally can't beat it it has a
design which you can click anywhere and
right here it looks like it doesn't have
one but check this out with three
fingers just like that you have a
virtual track pad that pops up and you
can even resize it and then move it
around if you want to now believe it or
not even though this is on the display I
honestly like this trackpad better than
any other Windows laptop yes any other
laptop because it's using a display and
software that works very well compared
to those crappy diving board track pads
on other laptops but check this out you
can also go like this if you tap with
all of your fingers boom virtual
keyboard and a full trackpad look at
this all the way around pops up and
honestly Lenovo did an excellent job
with this trackpad and you really got to
get used to it because there's no
feedback but it works very very well
it's very responsive but of course the
physical track pad on the MacBook Pro is
amazing you can't really beat that
physical feel but in exchange the Lenovo
gives you two whole displays so let's
get into that but it also comes with
the keyboard check this out you just pop
it out just like this
there you go a Bluetooth keyboard that
works just like this you turn it on and
there you go
you're typing so the nice thing about
this is that you have flexibility to
move it around however you'd like type
with it it feels very very nice and
responsive but check this out it also
comes with another feature there you go
you plop it on and it has magnets built
in so it connects right flush with the
actual Lenovo book and it opens up this
new UI where check this out you have
another display with some news articles
you can log into your emails all while
working with a touch screen right here
on the top display this is very very
clever and I've got to say I'm quite
impressed with this touch screen it's
not that reflective compared to a lot of
other touchscreen Windows laptops so
this is really nice great contrast due
to the OLED I'm very very impressed with
it of course the MacBook Pro doesn't
have any kind of touch screen or
anything like that so this is really
Innovative and another thing the MacBook
can't do is this is they're going to
fold down flat on the table as you can
see cannot happen on the MacBook Pro now
before I get into comparing everything
like the cameras the speakers the
display quality and the performance I
want to set the MacBook Pro aside and
show off all the different modes you
could use these displays in now the
first mode is to lay it down flat like
this where you could basically use the
pen to draw let's say you have Photoshop
or some other app open you could even
spin it like this move it around while
you're drawing which is really cool and
unique they also have 10 modes so you
basically just fold it back like this as
you can see you
display on both sides and it
automatically adjusts the orientation
now the cool thing about this is that
you could be working on some kind of
presentation and then everybody in front
of you can see what you're kind of
presenting to them or let's say you're
working on your laptop and you have your
kid watching some cartoons on the back
that's actually a really cool use case
now the other modes work very well with
the keyboard but this one I kind of
overlooked at the beginning check this
out you plop it on right there at the
top
and now automatically you get your
trackpad on the bottom just like a
traditional laptop you have your
keyboard up top so you can do your
typing and of course your trackpad with
the buttons right here of course if you
don't you could take your keyboard and
stick it down here that way you get your
full dual displays and your keyboard at
the same time and here is the next mode
where you basically prop it up using the
little keyboard case which is really
cool and then even the keyboard
magnetically attaches right here right
into this little divot and as you can
see I have vertical displays right here
so basically you could be doing some
research online while doing some file
app things moving stuff around or
whatever else you'd like and then you
could also grab it and flip it up like
this and that way you kind of have a
dual display setup that you can kind of
set further away from you change that
angle and then use a mouse and keyboard
to control it and now let's get into
comparing the display quality as you
know the Lenovo has two displays that
are actually identical displays as you
can see we have HDR videos playing right
here and I've got to say I'm impressed
by the brightness because usually the
MacBooks get a lot brighter than Windows
laptops and this is right up there the
contrast ratio looks amazing the colors
look amazing and in terms of the specs
it has 2.8 K resolution per display 13.3
inches the same 16 by 10 aspect ratio as
the MacBook Pro but they are 60 hertz
panels while the MacBook Pro goes up to
120 and the really awesome thing is that
it also supports Dolby Vision with 100
DCI P3 colors just like the MacBook Pro
that is really impressive especially
since they're packing two of the same
display on this thing now on top of that
usually Windows laptops especially ones
with touch screens are very reflective
but looking at it right here it's
basically the same as the MacBook Pro
that is incredibly incredibly impressive
and I've got to say I don't think I've
seen a better OLED display on any other
laptop props to Lenovo but what about
the speakers let's compare them with
this song
[Music]
so as you guys just heard the MacBook
Pro dominated the Lenovo which usually
happens it always destroys Windows
laptops but honestly this was pretty
impressive for only having the speakers
in a sound bar and we've seen many many
more Windows laptops that sound much
worse than this so it was honestly
pretty good however there is a lot more
bass on the MacBook Pro as well as the
Sound Stage and kind of hearing all the
different frequencies separately the
MacBook Pro killed it in that way and
the Lenovo mostly focused on kind of the
mids and highs so it's good for vocals
but not as good for music and now let's
get into comparing the webcams
surprisingly this has a 1440p video
video webcam and right here it looks
pretty good you guys let me know what
you think and also about the microphone
quality as well and then here is the 14
inch MacBook Pro with its 1080p quality
webcam so you guys let me know what the
difference is down in the comment
section below and now let's get into
performance the Lenovo comes with a new
Raptor Lake i7
1355u with 16 gigs of RAM and a one
terabyte SSD which is very nice the
MacBook Pro on the other hand has a 512
gig SSD at the base price and a Bend 10
core M2 Pro chip that has two less
performance cores and of course it also
has 16 gigs of RAM so let's go ahead and
start the CPU test and there you go we
have our scores and this is actually
impressive because this thing is not
really designed for pro productivity
workflows it's basically for General use
with the Dual displays being the coolest
feature and surprisingly the MacBook Pro
is only 16 faster in terms of single
core and 45 faster and multi-core so
this is definitely going to be the one
if you're doing video editing or other
productivity work and now I'm running
the graphics test to see if the MacBook
is going to destroy the Lenovo and wow
that is a massive difference the MacBook
Pro score is over four times higher so
this basically means that this Lenovo
laptop you don't really want to do any
gaming or kind of like video editing
photo editing anything that relies on a
lot of graphics performance because it
is really really lacking but of course
for General use multitasking and stuff
like that that is definitely enough and
now with all that said let's jump into
the conclusion is the Lenovo book 9i
better than the MacBook Pro well
honestly I've got to say I'm impressed
with the Dual displays very very high
quality the fact that it has a 360
degree hinge is amazing for all those
different modes that you can use and in
terms of the battery life it should get
around seven to nine hours even with the
Dual displays because a lot of people
think with these huge dual displays it
probably eats a lot of battery life well
it's actually very very good compared to
other Windows laptops it's not as good
as the MacBook Pro which could get 11 to
12 but it's still very impressive with
these two displays and that is because
they stuffed a huge 80 watt hour battery
in this thing which is very surprising
due to its portability compared to about
69 Watt hours on the MacBook Pro but
with that said I've got to say that this
thing is absolutely incredible there's
just so many different ways you can use
it it's awesome for multitasking you
don't have to go out and get an external
monitor like you have to do with the
MacBook Pro it's all in one it has a
stylus additional keyboard just so much
value packed in for the price so I've
got to say if I were a regular user that
didn't need any kind of performance
things like gaming or video editing I
would probably go with this thing right
here because it is really cool and
Innovative so hopefully you enjoy this
video and if you did you can find the
links to this Lenovo laptop down into
the description below as well as the
mobile pixels geminos dual stack display
hopefully you enjoyed it click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign